starwars the rise of Skywalker is
devided fans in a big way and perhaps we
shouldn't be too surprised about that
the final installment of the Skywalker
saga hit theaters on Thursday December
19th and since then responses to the
film have been pouring in across social
media so far professional critics
haven't been particularly impressed by
the movie with many reviewers arguing
that the installment provides too much
fanservice and too little substance
meanwhile plenty of viewers have taken
to Twitter to both praise and scorn the
film honestly reactions have been all
over the map
make no mistake plenty of die-hard Star
Wars fans stayed up late on Thursday
night to catch the premiere and many of
them had nothing but good things to say
about the film one fan tweeted I loved
it for me it provided perfect closure
the acting the effects the action
sequences all brilliant I've loved star
wars since the 80s and I was not let
down by rise of Skywalker
to all those involved from past the
present I thank you at least one
longtime fan of the franchise fully
agreed with that assessment
writing the rise of Skywalker embodies
everything I love about Star Wars and it
never skips a beat a perfect ending to
the Skywalker saga take it from a kid
born in 1977 it's epic another fan
praised the lead performances and the
direction in no uncertain terms tweeting
JJ Abrams did an incredible job I felt
every second of this movie the acting is
the best I've seen in Star Wars history
Daisy Ridley and Adam driver killed it
given the controversial reaction to the
last Jedi in 2017
perhaps we shouldn't be too shocked that
some fans heaped praise on the rise of
Skywalker while totally bashing its
predecessor one such fan tweeted forget
the bad reviews this is a blast JJ
Abrams managed to fix the Rian Johnson
mess from the last movie and give a
thrill ride at the same time the fans
will love it great job adding fuel to
the fire another fan wrote that the rise
of Skywalker is a great movie and it's
the best one out of the new trilogy the
last Jedi was a disaster of a movie and
JJ Abrams did what he could to save the
series meanwhile countless fans of the
franchise were deeply disappointed by
the film and they certainly didn't hold
back when it came to voicing that
displeasure one detractor tweeted after
a second viewing I can confidently say
that Star Wars 9 rise of Skywalker blows
it's the perfect confluence of horrible
pacing uncomfortable close-ups terribly
inconsistent use of their own
and for Star Wars cliches at nauseam
another viewer was similarly unimpressed
tweeting rise of Skywalker was
absolutely terrible
you could tell JJ really tried but it
was a mess a sequel to a movie we never
saw on the other hand one fan seemed
totally conflicted tweeting the rise of
Skywalker is the worst movie I have ever
loved it was a dumpster fire of
fanfiction Tropes that made no sense
there was no character development that
made sense there were no stakes it was a
trash movie but it was my trash rest
assured plenty of big names shared their
reactions to and those reactions run the
gamut from delight to disgust fanboys
director Kyle Newman was clearly
satisfied with the film writing advice
to fellow Star Wars fans don't let the
critics get you down go have a blast at
the theater there are so many great
things about the rise of Skywalker it's
flawed but it's fun and don't forget to
bring that kid who lives inside you as
your guest they'll dig it on the other
hand English writer director and actor
Jack Howard tweeted that the rise of
Scott Walker ends the new trilogy with a
disappointing whimper it plays out like
a fan film backpedaling decisions in the
last Jedi in favor of connecting dots to
satisfy a specific group rather than
tell an original story it feels like the
series is at war with itself ESPN writer
Ryan McGee revealed his own thoughts on
the film tweeting that I haven't looked
at the tomato meter for rise of
Skywalker because I legitimately don't
care
took my daughter like a half her whole
life and we laughed and cried and went
whoa and had a hell of a time just like
I did with my family 30-plus years ago
to me that's the magic of it as we said
reactions are all over the place and we
don't expect the debates to die down
anytime soon on the upside at least the
rise of Skywalker has made us all stop
talking about the my clunky debacle
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you